[Música]
el fiscal general de Estados Unidos
nombró a Jack Smith como fiscal especial
para el caso de las investigaciones
federales contra el expresidente Donald
Trump por el manejo de documentos
clasificados Smith catalogado de
Independiente era hasta ahora el fiscal
jefe del tribunal especial de la haya
en Venezuela la ong líderes libres y
algunos periodistas protestaron este
viernes en Caracas por el cierre
sistemático de medios de comunicación
por orden del gobierno hasta 106
emisoras de radio habrían sido cerradas
arbitrariamente según la ong
el estado de Nueva York y otros estados
circundantes a la región de los grandes
lagos en Estados Unidos y ven la primera
gran tormenta de nieve de la temporada
invernal se espera que la Nevada pueda
ser histórica en el estado de Nueva York
con hasta casi un metro y medio de nieve
acumulada Tenemos reporte
Bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este Informativo en
Estados Unidos en donde el fiscal
general anunció el nombramiento de Jack
Smith como fiscal especial para que
supervise las investigaciones federales
existentes contra Álex presidente Donald
Trump que involucran el manejo de
documentos clasificados que el
expresidente tenía en su mansión de Mara
lago Smith era hasta este momento fiscal
jefe del tribunal especial de la haya
Andrés granadillo con los detalles en el
siguiente informe
un abogado especial que supervisará las
investigaciones del departamento de
justicia a Donald Trump que involucran
el manejo de documentos clasificados que
tenía el expresidente en su mansión de
Mara lago y su supuestos intentos de
interferir en el traspaso Pacífico del
poder tras las elecciones de 2020
Oye firmado una orden por la que se
nombra Jack Smith provocado especial la
orden la autoriza a continuar la
investigación en curso y a perseguir
cualquier delito federal que pueda
surgir de estas investigaciones
catalogado como un profesional
independiente y hasta ahora era fiscal
jefe del tribunal especial de la haya
encargado de procesar los crímenes de
guerra en kosovo anteriormente supervisó
la sección de integridad pública del
departamento de justicia y trabajó como
fiscal federal y estatal en Nueva York
el nombramiento llega a tres días
después de que Trump anunciara que se
lanzará por tercera vez a la carrera por
la Casa Blanca en 2024
creo firmemente que los procesos
normales de este departamento pueden
manejar todas las investigaciones con
integridad y también Creo que nombrar un
abogado especial en este momento es lo
correcto las circunstancias
extraordinarias que se presentan aquí lo
exigen
el nombramiento de Smith pretende evitar
algún tipo de conflicto de intereses que
pueda surgir en la investigación Este es
el tercer un Héroes especial del
departamento de Justicia que se nombra
desde 2017 cuando el ex director del FBI
Robert investigó la campaña presidencial
de Trump en 2016 y sus contactos con
Rusia el viceministro de exteriores
rusos serguéi informó que fueron
retomadas las negociaciones con Estados
Unidos para un intercambio de
prisioneros
Moscú pretende la ansiada liberación del
Traficante de armas Víctor Boat a cambio
de la basquetbolista Britney grayner
quien fue derivada a mordovia una región
carcelaria de tiempos soviéticos y fue
condenada además a nueve años de prisión
por posesión de drogas Ramiro Cuevas
verena tiene los detalles en el
siguiente informe
Britney grainer puede ser la llave de
Rusia para recuperar a Víctor vaugh la
figura del apodo mercader de la muerte
objetivo de Moscú desde su detención en
2008 está sobre la mesa de negociaciones
en un intercambio que incluiría a la
basquetbolista estrella y Alex Marín
Paul
el viceministro de exteriores ruso
sarguey reabcop dio pocos detalles pero
se mostró optimista
quiero esperar que la perspectiva no
solo permanezca sino que se fortalezca y
que llegue el momento en que logremos un
acuerdo concreto estamos trabajando
profesionalmente a través de un canal
especial diseñado para esto Víctor Boat
está entre los que se están discutiendo
y ciertamente Contamos con un resultado
positivo
por su parte Estados Unidos recalcó las
fallas constantes de Rusia en las
conversaciones este viernes el portavoz
adjunto del departamento de estado vean
papel afirmó que el kremlin no negoció
seriamente por los canales establecidos
entretanto griner fue derivada mordovia
conocida desde la época soviética por
sus colonias penales
las cárceles de mujeres de mordovia como
el centro Correccional dos donde Britney
ha sido enviada son muy conocidas entre
los defensores de los Derechos Humanos
por sus horribles condiciones de trabajo
las mujeres allí son castigadas castigan
a la unidad que tiene la culpa cuando no
han trabajado lo suficiente no reciben
agua caliente por días
Rusia y Estados Unidos tienen
antecedentes en intercambios de
prisioneros pero Washington siempre fue
reticente a liberar about sin embargo la
estadía de griner en mordovia puede
cambiar el panorama seguimos ahora con
noticias de América Latina y nos vamos
hasta Venezuela la ong líderes libres y
algunos periodistas protestaron este
viernes en Caracas la capital del país
por lo que denuncian es el cierre
sistemático de medios de comunicación
por orden del gobierno de Nicolás maduro
según denuncia esta ong se han cerrado
106 emisoras de radio arbitrariamente
sin que el gobierno haya dado las
razones para ello si bien la agencia Efe
indica que algunas tenían su licencia
caducada y no pidieron renovarlas estos
cierres habrían afectado a 1.500
trabajadores de la comunicación en
Venezuela escuchemos a uno de los
manifestantes
lo que va de 10 meses han cerrado 106
emisoras de radio arbitrariamente
incorrectamente un proceso totalmente
viciado de conatel no han pedido del Por
qué este cierre ni siquiera han dado el
derecho a la defensa y el derecho a ni
siquiera a presentar aunque sea un
documento o algo para que mantenga las
radios abiertas y en Perú un avión de
pasajeros que se prestaba a despegar del
aeropuerto de Lima rumbo a la ciudad de
juliaca impacto un vehículo de
emergencias que invadió la pista
principal del aeropuerto dos bomberos
murieron en el acto tras el impacto con
el ala y el motor del lado derecho este
quedó envuelto en llamas las autoridades
peruanas indicaron que el avión se
detuvo a un lado de la pista y de
inmediato se dio total atención a la
emergencia y a la evacuación de los
pasajeros que resultaron ilesos una
investigación del hecho ya fue puesta en
marcha el aeropuerto de Lima suspendió
sus operaciones hasta nueva orden
en Ecuador una serie de enfrentamientos
ocurridos al interior de la cárcel del
inca ubicada en Quito dejó al menos 10
prisioneros muertos esta nueva masacre
carcelaria tuvo lugar cuando un
cabecilla de una banda criminal fue
trasladado a una cárcel de máxima
seguridad en Guayaquil el gobierno lo
culpaba de un suceso similar anterior
que dejó cinco fallecidos en el mismo
penal en medio de la escalada de
violencia desatada por diversas bandas
criminales en Ecuador
y nos vamos a Estados Unidos en Nueva
York nuestra corresponsal mamen nos
mamen sala nos ampliaba anteriormente
sobre las tormentas de nieve que azotan
el oeste del estado de Nueva York y
otros estados circundantes a la región
de los grandes lagos que se despertaron
ya este viernes con acumulaciones de más
de medio metro de nieve las tormentas
podrían durar hasta el domingo y dejar
acumulados históricos para la fecha
Sí aquí la situación es cada vez más
complicada ya hay alrededor de 6
millones de personas que se encuentran
bajo alerta por tormenta de nieve en
cinco estados en los grandes lagos desde
Wisconsin hasta Nueva York aquí la peor
parte se la está llevando Búfalo allí
las autoridades han dicho que se trata
de una tormenta histórica que no se veía
algo igual desde el 2014 cuando
precisamente una tormenta de nieve acabó
con la vida de 20 personas es lo que han
dicho las autoridades para que los
ciudadanos se hagan una idea de lo
peligrosa que es la situación de hecho
la gobernadora del estado de Nueva York
catio chull ha decretado el estado de
emergencia en al menos 11 condados en
estos momentos como digo la peor parte
se la está llevando Búfalo y seguirá
avanzando cada vez a peor a medida que
nos acerquemos a la noche Allí se han
cerrado escuelas a lo largo del día de
hoy se han cerrado oficinas se han
cerrado carreteras incluso carreteras
principales porque la cantidad de nieve
que estaba cayendo y la intensidad era
tal que ni siquiera las máquinas
quitanieve más fuertes han podido
limpiar las carreteras además también se
han suspendido varios vuelos y las
autoridades no se cansan de repetir a
los ciudadanos que no salgan de su casa
que por supuesto No cojan el coche
con este reporte de nuestra corresponsal
en Nueva York y las imágenes de esta
primera Nevada de la temporada invernal
en el estado homónimo Nos despedimos de
este telediario yo les invito a que
sigan conectados a France 24 y Recuerden
que pueden ampliar toda esta y mucha más
información en nuestro sitio web France
24.com
[Música]